hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host John Carroll
existentialism has an interesting place
in philosophy and the history of
philosophy many of you might know that
modern Western philosophy can often be
divided very roughly into two parts
there's sort of the analytic tradition
with logic and Mathematics and
epistemology and metaphysics and a
scientific Outlook then there is the
Continental tradition which is more
about the human side of things reading
texts interpreting things more
philosophy is literature than philosophy
as science in that classification
existentialism is absolutely on the
Continental side of things the image
that gets conjured up is people in
France sitting around a cafe table
either drinking coffee or cocktails
smoking cigarettes talking about the
meaning of life right but in some ways
existentialism is a response a taking
seriously to and of the scientific view
of the world the existentialism grew out
of of concerns on the part of people
like Nietzsche and Kierkegaard and
Dostoyevsky that the world was becoming
disenchanted that we didn't have the
rules that had been handed down by God
anymore we had to find meaning for
ourselves uh there's a motto in
existentialism that existence precedes
essence
in other words things exist that's what
actually is out there in the world and
the essence of a thing the thing that
makes a rock a rock or a person a person
in some way these are categories that we
human beings attach to them which is
actually a very modern scientific way of
thinking about things it's very in tune
with poetic naturalism I should say So
today we're going to talk about
existentialism with Sky Cleary who is an
expert in the subject and the author of
a new book how to be authentic Simone de
bevoir and the Quest for fulfillment the
idea being all right let's confront this
world that does not have these objective
guidances from the outside it's we human
beings in the universe that are in
charge of things and in particular it is
we individuals who are in charge of
creating our own lives yes it is true we
are made of particles and Fields or
we're made of cells and neurons and
whatever but as human beings as agents
even though we have predilections and
preferences and intuitions we also have
the ability to reflect on them to decide
to change them to create who we are
ourselves to be true to ourselves by
rebelling against standardized norms and
expectations of the rest of the world
that's what it means to be authentic and
I think like with many kinds of
philosophies that try to talk about the
meaning of life and how to be a good
person it's not science or math at the
end of the day it's not something that
is right or wrong and that's the whole
story it's a question of can we find
something useful in it can we be
inspired or be provoked to think about
things in a new way and by that standard
a new and productive way let's say by
that standard I think it's absolutely
interesting to talk about this subject
was famous for many reasons not just
being an existentialist but for being
extremely important feminist philosopher
especially at a time when that was not
necessarily the popular position there
and there's a lot for us to learn by
thinking about how she thought about
life and the mistakes that she made as
well as the insights that she had so
let's go
[Music]
guy Cleary welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you Sean it's great to be
here we're going to talk about primarily
SMUD bovoir you've written a book about
her and sort of updated some of her
thoughts to the modern world with your
own thoughts but of course she's very
much in this existentialist tradition so
I thought that we should
set the stage a little bit about
existentialism it's clearly a very
influential School of philosophy but
also maybe not one that is being
championed actively by a majority of
people in the academy right now so
there's an interesting history there
clearly uh where did it come from there
were precursors to existentialism maybe
we should start there
you're right some
some do
um dismiss it as sort of a mood of of
the 20th century
um but you know there are still
existential questions that keep popping
up you know people are still asking
questions about why are we here what are
we doing what should we do how do we get
along with other people so these are all
um very solid existential questions and
this is one of the reasons why people
like me and many others are still
writing books
um about existentialism all these years
later
um and so just to put it in a little
historical context as as you uh were
asking about uh so I mean
existentialism kind of grew out of uh
Romanticism and so we had the agent of
Enlightenment where
science was flourishing and was
answering lots of lots of questions
about how the world Works
um but romanticism
kind of said well what about things like
emotions and love and fun and creativity
and all these other sorts of
um questions that science wasn't able to
answer and so then
um but Romanticism also had a a kind of
spiritual angle to it
um but existentialism
um kind of some of the uh I guess
precursors or grandfathers of
existentialism were people like
Kierkegaard and and Nietzsche and kihu
God was um writing in um kind of
rebellion against uh philosophers like
Hegel and Kant who were very abstract
and thinking about wanting to create
systems to explain how the world works
from a philosophical perspective whereas
um Kiki God was much more interested in
Um passion and how that relay relates to
acting ethically in the world and how
that relates to religion
um and then of course Frederick
Nietzsche was also uh similar to
Kierkegaard was very much in Rebellion
against all those traditional
philosophies and and religion too and
nature is famous for saying well God is
dead
um and but we have killed him is is
um
that full quote there and he was saying
you know religion used to be the primary
way that people would organize that
their world and understand meaning in
their lives but now that science came
along and explains a lot about about the
world
um you know we still act
um with
um religious underpinnings particularly
I guess um you know Christian
Commandments of you know be nice and do
not kill thy neighbor and things like
that
um and so nature was saying well we're
still operating in a world based on
these kind of religious values but so
few people are um like really believe in
religion anymore and so he was kind of
questioning and which is why one of the
reasons he wrote in aphorisms and stuff
because he was challenging people
um and so the existential philosophers
kind of Grew From that tradition
and they became particularly popular
around the 1940s around you know after
two world wars when people were
um you know was a particularly
tumultuous period in in history and
people were asking questions like
um well faced with a Nazi occupation of
France and
um so particularly and satra were were
asking okay well
if you're being tortured and you have
this Choice as to whether
um you know tell the torturers you know
where your friends are or
um you know don't tell them and risk
death you know these are really intense
choices that we're making and these
aren't choices that necessarily science
or religion can answer and so this is
one of the reasons why existentialism
kind of flourish because they were
talking about choices
um Freedom anxiety responsibility and
and authenticity that's a very
interesting answer because it's a very
kind of positive answer starting with
Romantics and everything like usually I
hear that existentialism grew out of
this dread and worry that we had like
you said about Nietzsche you know lost
our objective
stances or foundations of of moralities
so is it right to say the
existentialists
fought against that
by just buying into it like they're like
yes there isn't any objective stance for
Morality or meaning out there therefore
we can create it ourselves
yeah they they definitely built on on
nature
um and yeah it is it does tend to
um be portrayed as like a gloomy
philosophy because partly because
um Jean-Paul thought is one of the most
pretty much the most famous existential
philosopher
um and he does take a little bit more of
a of a gloomy view of human nature
whereas I think my more positive
interpretation comes from who
um argued pretty heavily that
existentialism isn't all about Doom and
Gloom it's a very positive
um philosophy because it's all about
seizing control of of what we can
um you know she's she's has some like a
couple of stoic roots in there I think
like by um you know the dichotomy of
control like but acknowledging
um she she calls it Factory City and
Transcendence so there are the factory
is uh like they're the facts of Our
Lives they're the things we can't change
like we can't change that we were born
we can't change who our parents are we
can't change the situations that that we
were came into we can't change you know
the bodies we were born with although
there are some ways that we can change
that now
um but uh you know and her point was
trying to acknowledge
um though those facts of our existence
but where existentialism comes in is in
that window of Freedom where we can
um overcome our facticity where we can
transcend beyond the given and that sort
of transcending in ways that we choose
is is where authenticity comes in
so
the the yeah the the transcending and
the choosing and the freedom I do Wonder
uh how this fits in with modern science
I get the impression that uh
existentialists were pro-science they
weren't trying to you know uh resist
some of that and I personally
philosophically am a compatibleist about
Free Will and so forth but if we brought
Robert sapolski in here the
neuroscientist who was a previous guest
on the podcast he'd be like what do you
mean making choices these are all just
neurons in your brain they're they were
trained by Evolution and everything is
that is that perspective in any way
undermining the existential point of
view
I I think it's raising questions about
it but existentialism raises questions
for science as well so you know not all
Neuroscience scientists are
deterministic in that way and there does
seem to be research to suggest that we
can override our impulses and we can
there are choices that that we we can
make in life and so existentialism is
um more I guess in sync with with that
kind of view like yes there we have
brains they're part of our Factory and
you know we have genes also part of our
Factory but what's interesting for the
existentialists and again this is part
of the positive perspective is what's
interesting is to figure out where that
window of freedom is to figure out where
we can
um exercise our Free Will where we can
you know make choices in in our lives
and you know there's a lot of literature
sure on the plasticity of our brains as
well and how we can you know retrain
them to or you know um uh reorient our
brains and learn new skills and learn to
do new things and that's very compatible
with with existential philosophy yeah I
I again I'm I think I'm on your side
here but I'm just I've heard a lot of uh
alternative perspectives that I know are
going to get riled up by this kind of
discourse because what they're going to
ask is who is the we that are changing
our minds like certainly our minds do
change is there an extent to which we
can say we are changing our minds rather
than our minds got changed I think the
answer is yes and I think that that's
compatible with existentialism do they
have a take on that or is that just not
considered a central question
um so I I think the way I want to answer
this is with the idea that we we as
humans are creative nothings so what I
mean by that is that there's no like
necessarily fixed self that we will
always be referring back to but rather
we are creative beings who make choices
who overcome those facts of Our Lives
who can Orient ourselves in new ways who
can recreate our being
um
and so what the existentials focus on is
that kind of creative aspect of our our
um our being and so you know this is
part of the point of Jean-Paul satra's
most famous work being a nothingness
he's like yes we as humans We Exist we
are this being we have this meat suit
but we are also nothingness in in the
sense that whether some of our past
actions we are these beings who who are
making choices now and we're also beings
who are setting intentions about where
we want our lives to go and that sort of
trajectory is never completed until
death but that gap between what we who
we are now and that collection of
choices that we've made about ourselves
and and the the way Society I guess has
shaped us and and how genetics and
everything else is shaped who we are now
that up between that our present State
and the future and death that space is
nothingness that's what he calls like a
not yet or a lack and you know and the
way we project ourselves into that
future is
um the space of Freedom the space of
creativity the space of choice making
existentialists talk about death a lot
more than most philosophers do
[Laughter]
yeah they do
um and you know that's that you know
it's funny that
um
you know existentialists have a
reputation for being atheists but some
of them weren't some of them were
religious like Kierkegaard
um but what they the key point about
death and why it's so important is that
death kind of puts a hard stop on our
lives and you know even for the atheists
philosophers it doesn't even matter what
happens after death what death means is
that there's no more of this particular
life yeah and no more of our our
existence in in this earth and and what
they thought was that that sort of hard
stop
meant that every moment is valuable all
the choices we make are have
consequences for our lives and for other
people's lives and so that kind of
limits they thought should help us to
appreciate life in all its Glory right
now
yeah no I'm actually a big believer that
we don't talk about death enough so to
me this is one of the great points in
the favor of existentialism I actually
did one of the very first podcasts I did
was with Megan Rosenbloom about the
death positive movement that we should
face up to death a lot more explicitly
and and plan for it so that's good for
them so okay uh with that with that sort
of groundwork out of the way let's let's
and again before getting directly into
Deborah specifically by the way should i
is her last name bouvoir or de bouvoir
um so the current standard is to say
without the and there's um and so that's
kind of that's the the trend at the at
the moment I would like to be trendy so
I will do that okay good
so maybe you guys get on the table there
are some you know positive claims that
come from existentialism or somebody
some Central ideas around which the
discussion is based and they're you know
they're in your book uh so one of them
which I I quite like even though it's
one of those things where it makes no
sense when I first hear it I have to
think about it is existence precedes
essence
if I got that right tell us what that
means
wow
and you
had to existentialism in three in three
words that would
um and the idea is related to what we've
already talked about so far is that the
uh existential philosophers thought that
we're thrown into the world thrown-ness
is kind of a Heidi gearing word that a
lot of um the philosophers came to to
sort of embrace so we're thrown into the
world we don't choose to be here but
once we do it's up to us to create our
Essence so we're not born with like a
soul we're not born with a fixed thing
and fixed trajectory inside of us but we
are creative beings and to live an
authentic life is to create our Essence
in ways that we choose but while
acknowledging that we live in in a
society and we co-exist with other
people
so good so if I and like I said I love
this little encapsulation I think it's
one of those things that is too pithy to
be understandable without the extra
explanation after the fact but but I
like the claim that is being made I mean
there are facts there is uh existence
like you say but who we are in some
grander sense how we think of ourselves
how we would go about describing
ourselves in some sense comes later like
it very much fits into an idea that
there's a microscopic comprehensive
physical view of reality and then
there's a higher level description that
we use at the human level right I mean
they were inventing emergence before
physicists uh use those words
yeah definitely and it I mean and when I
say we're creating our essence or it's
up to us to create our Essence
um I mean for example Jean-Paul start in
being a nothingness was very much about
radical freedom and yes we're always
going to come up against obstacles but
it's our choice whether to push
ourselves up against those obstacles or
to you know choose not to go climb that
mountain nod to choose to you know take
a different path
um but he kind of moderated his views
later and and I think this was also
because of full vile's influence and
bewafa was much more
um kind of sympathetic or realistic
depending on how you look at it two
um like the the pressures that that we
all face you know not all of us can just
go out in the world and do whatever we
want and we actually shouldn't go out
and do whatever we want because there
are other people there and our actions
have consequences and so she was very
much acknowledging that there are social
economic
um uh historical I guess limitations on
on how we can exercise our freedom and
um one of the the words that that
um people are using
um to describe this is sedimentation and
so while's idea is that we grow up and
we sort of gather like you know like
something like a river you know we go
through life and We Gather you know a
lot of sediment that shapes who we
become like like Jean-Paul sartre's idea
of us being the sum of our actions
though all those actions you know kind
of shape who we are today but it's not
um you know and there are so many
different different influences on us
pushing and pulling us in different
directions you know like you said you
know maybe there are you know brain
Pathways and stuff that that are fixed
um and but uh you know it's kind of
depressing I think for the egg for me
and for the existential philosophers to
think that oh we're just you know these
um blind uh you know bodies
um going through life and this is one of
the reasons I I really like
existentialism because it does
open up that window of Freedom it does
say yeah sure there's all these things
all these pressures on us but what's
important is looking for what we can
choose looking for ways we can take
control over our lives and and become
the kind of people we want to be
I I like the idea of sedimentation it
reminds me of recently and I forget the
source I'm very sorry but I was reading
about how to handle grief like when
something very terrible happens to you
and the idea is not that you get over it
but that it becomes part of you and you
know you don't you don't forget the
terrible thing that happened uh but you
bring it into who you are and and never
let it go but still function as a person
is that a is that a related I don't I
didn't associate that with
existentialism but it sounds like maybe
it fits in
yeah it does sound like it fits in I
don't know I'm Karen Satya has written a
book about this this recently
um I think it's called life is tough and
yeah he also talks about grief and not
necessarily from it from an existential
perspective although there are
existential elements in there but yeah I
mean you can't change that someone you
love has died
um that's that's part of who you are
that's part of your experiences and I
think the um well at least Simone de
Beauvoir would
um uh argue that that's an um you know
important part of that becomes an
important part of our existence and
funny story okay not so funny but um the
interesting story between
um bouvoir and Saad
um so
um at some point boudoir's mother died
and Bourgeois was really
um sad about it and she was crying and
but
um and she was partners with John Paul
sart and so but
tears really annoyed Jean-Paul Sartre
and so Bourgeois started to take
um medication so that she would stop
crying in Jean-Paul sartre's presence
um because Jean-Paul Satchel was of the
view that you know emotions are choices
emotions are strategies for coping in
the world and so I'm much so even the
existential philosophers disagreed on a
lot of course sort of thing of course
um as philosophers do
um but I'm you know I think Bourgeois
was much more spot on in in this realm
in that it's okay to to show emotions
it's okay to
um you know live and and feel all the
feels through throughout life and
um that's and you know it's important to
move on at some point and and not to get
stuck in that in in that space But you
know
it's still important to recognize that
experience as part of our Factory and
still to you know when it's time to to
think more about transcending and
stretching ourselves forward again
well that leads very well into you know
the other two
pillars of existentials I just invented
these as the fullest of existentialism
sorry about that but the words that I
keep hearing uh freedom is obviously one
of them but we you know we've talked
about that the crucial aspect there and
the other is authenticity which you've
already used it's in the title of your
book uh clearly it was very important so
what does it mean in this particular
context
yeah so the way I Define authenticity is
that it's a process of creating your
essence
so a couple of things there first of all
authenticity is a process you know often
we hear people talking about
authenticity or people say oh yeah I'm
I'm really authentic but for the
existential philosophers you know
authenticity isn't like a certificate
you can hang on your wall and like I'm
authentic now I've done it I've found
that that gem or that blueprint in my
soul and now I've got it and now I can
just listen to that thing and it'll tell
me what to do and it'll tell me what to
make what's going to make me happy so no
that for the existential philosophers
um authenticity is it's a creative
process it's embracing our freedom
transcending making choices about who we
want to become
um and it relates back to what we were
talking about before which so it's a pro
authenticity is a process of creating
your essence and so it's that essence
isn't something we're born with it's
something that we create as we go
through life and as we build up that
sediment and drag along our past like
like a ball and chain behind us
um but it's a very liberating way to
look at it I think look at authenticity
because it means okay maybe you haven't
made such authentic choices in your past
but it's never too late it's we can
always start thinking about our space of
freedom and and who we want to become
right now
um and and the other thing I like about
this is particularly Bourgeois kind of
formulation of authenticity is that
she's not really telling us how to be
authentic specifically even though the
title of my book is how to be authentic
that's a little bit tongue-in-cheek and
what I'm saying is that you know there's
sort of a way that there are these words
that we're talking about Freedom Choice
facticity Transcendence authenticity and
understanding kind of these these
Frameworks and and these ideas
um is a way of kind of phrasing our
Consciousness to to understand uh what's
authentic for us but you know
authenticity is actually something that
each of us needs to to figure out on our
own and so boovar really is she's just
sharing some kind of guidelines and
important things to keep in mind
so I guess I by the idea that we're
creating our own Essences I think that's
genius I love it but there seems to be
an implication that we could do that
inauthentically right that some
processes of creating who we are are
fake and authentic whatever you want to
call it what is the difference if we're
certainly creating our own Essences how
do we know that we're doing it
authentically versus some other way
yeah this is a good question and in
authenticity or what the existential is
called bad faith is was was a big
Challenge and you know the main
um I guess criteria for choosing things
authentically as opposed to
inauthentically is being Lucid about
what you're doing like trying to
understand
[Applause]
um whether it's you choosing or whether
you're just doing things because other
people are pressuring you into it like
are you getting married because you
genuinely want to get married or are you
doing it just because it's what your
family and Society expects of you and
your brain impression into it and it's
really hard to tell sometimes whether
we're acting authentically or
inauthentically and you know what what
and it's it's and sometimes where often
actually we're making choices almost
pre-reflectively and it's not like we
can stop every time we have to make a
choice and say oh is this authentic or
inauthentic no I mean we've got to live
and but while's point was that sometimes
we don't know if the choice we made was
consistent with who we want to be until
we've actually kind of leapt into the
choice and until we've actually done the
thing and figured out oh actually that
didn't have the consequences I intended
because none of us can predict the
future
um and although we can we can imagine
what certain consequences might be but
uh often we make mistakes often there
are unintended consequences and so often
we can only really understand whether
something was was aligned with what we
wanted to do after the fact and so her
philosophy is is kind of liberating
because it's um it incorporates like the
importance of those mistakes of learning
from what where we've done in the past
and and incorporates a mode of
reflection on on big choices and and
especially the existential leaps where
which are those big meaningful important
choices that are virtually impossible to
reverse and this is why in this the
existential leap kind of is one of God's
terms originally and
his point was that yeah the existential
leap is such a leap because we can't
always know where where we're gonna land
after after we jump and but our being
our uh you know our our Essence is
defined by making those leaps and you
know if we have to we we adjust but you
know if we're not going to develop as as
a human by just staying stagnant and not
making any meaningful decisions in our
life so authenticity seems to be related
to honesty or maybe just self-honesty
that you know the idea that there's an
alignment between our true inner desires
and what we're stating to the rest of
the world is why we're doing something
is that right
I mean honesty and self-honesty is
definitely
um you know a part of it but I mean and
even the existential philosophers
disagreed on this for example Jean-Paul
sart would say that
um you know what it's important to be
honest with yourself but being honest
with other people is a whole different
story but I think
um being yeah and I think Honesty with
yourself or I mean being
reflective about
who you are and who you've become and
and the choices you've made in the past
and and reflecting about you know what
you want to do with your life that kind
of
um Lucidity and Albert kind of talked
about Lucidity more and I think Lucidity
is probably more a
um a term that bouvoir uses as well like
being trying to be as Lucid as possible
about our situations being as Lucid as
possible about the different kind of
pressures on us and making choices with
that Lucidity but also while recognizing
we're not always going to have full
information about about you know any
situation
um but all we can do is just try and
think and try and be Lucid
um about about who we are and where
we're going
so modern philosophy is is often roughly
divided into analytic and Continental at
least in the English speaking or some
you know European centered world and
existentialism firmly I would say in the
Continental Camp right the Continental
philosophy is more about how we live our
lives and things like that analytic
philosophy is more like proving theorems
and logic uh but I get the impression
that modern Continental philosophy you
know in the post-modern era would be a
little bit more skeptical of
authenticity right they'd be a little
bit more or at least there's more room
in there for saying well look sometimes
we perform we we are inauthentic we put
on masks we're we're not expressing our
true inner self and that's okay
um about I'm sure I'm vastly
oversimplifying things but I don't know
is that is that a fair reading or is the
existentialist going to argue against
that like no you've gone too far
no I don't think the I I think what the
existentials would say is okay first of
all they would say we're not telling you
you have to be authentic we're telling
you that life can be richer deeper more
fulfilling if you do consider orienting
your life in authentic ways
and in fact John Paul sart said
specifically I'm not authentic I'm just
pointing the way for others so
um and you know and also authenticity
isn't something that's necessarily I
could say hey Sean you're not being
authentic right now like that's not for
me to judge authenticity is something
for each of us to assess on our own like
in through being Lucid about our
situations and through through
reflecting and so
um you know I can say oh Sean you know
thank you for being open about uh your
experiences or something but I can't but
it would be meaningless for me to judge
us you as to whether you're being
authentic or not because only we can do
that
um I can I can catch you in a lie or
something but that's more about honesty
not about
um authenticity
but back to your point about
um Continental philosophy and analytical
philosophy um yeah I mean you're you're
spot on that Continental philosophy 10
especially existentialism tends to be
more interested in
um the real world and like sorry the
real how to live like when I say real
world I mean kind of less abstract and a
quick story that um uh you may have
already heard
um but uh for listeners who haven't
heard
um one of my favorite stories is about
kind of the birth of existentialism
um when bouvoir and sat had finished
studying at the sobon and they were out
drinking at a bar and their friend
Raymond Aaron came and joined them and
Raymond Aaron had just been learning
about
um phenomenology
which is one of who saw Edmund tusol
kind of uh um was it was a
phenomenologist and so he'd been
learning about this and Raymond Aaron
said to bevoir and start if you're a
phenomenologist you could make a
philosophy out of that apricot cocktail
you're drinking
and such was like wow okay he said
something like finally there is
philosophy
um because what they'd been learning
about were all these very abstract kind
of system building philosophies that
seem so remote from everyday living and
so what excited Bhavan sought was this
this idea that okay yes you could think
about an apricot cocktail or
um you know think about your your
personal experiences or love
relationships and kind of analyze those
things philosophically so that was what
was exciting for them and bouvoir also
said in in one of her memoirs that she
had no interest in like building a
philosophical system to explain the
world but she was more interested in
kind of what obsessive Tendencies lead
people to want to build
um kind of big systems
um in life but she was more interested
in kind of um I think she said
um practical Solutions and and everyday
problems and which is one of the reasons
that she and many of the other
existential philosophers wrote novels
um to kind of play with these different
um situations and ways of being and it's
also why wrote Memoirs and and published
her letters and Diaries
okay two two things first very quickly
apricot cocktails
sound terrible that just sounds like
disgusting and I'm very sad that that's
what be what they were drinking
um but secondly you've given us a great
segue into what I wanted to talk about
next was more about the facticity or
sedimentary history of Simone de bavar
herself I mean part of your book is
using you know you're trying to say some
things that are true but you're
certainly using this one person's life
and work as a lens through which to do
it and she had quite a life so maybe
tell some of the listeners about where
she came from and why she was so
important
yeah sure
um okay I'll take your point about
apricot cocktails no I haven't really
had one before so but I've had cocktails
with fruity stuff in them and they were
good so I don't know
next time next time in New York yeah so
I mean surmountable I mean she was a
basic stuff born in like 1908 died in
1986.
um she can she grew up in Paris
um she was born into a family that had
been wealthy at some point but had lost
sort of their wealth by the time she was
a child and this is important for
bouvoir's life because at the time you
know in the early 1900s
um
as a woman
you were defined by who you were married
to really and because she didn't have a
dowry she couldn't get married and or at
least not married to someone
um you know of you know sufficient
social standing so she from a very early
age she was expected to go and work and
as she grew up she had other friends who
were kind of being groomed for marriage
and she was so grateful that she wasn't
um in in that same situation because if
she had to go and work she had a bit
more freedom not complete freedom
because
careers for women at that time were
fairly limited
um and in fact she came out well before
a book was published by Simone de
Beaufort just in the last year or two
um called the inseparables and it was an
unpublished manuscript
um that she wrote about her childhood
friendship and the the torment that one
of her best friends went through in
um being sort of prepared for marriage
and
um so yeah interesting side note uh so
yeah and so bouvoir was went went to
study at the sorbonne University she
hadn't had the same kind of high school
education as her male counterparts like
like Jean Paul sart but she was
I think the youngest person ever
to to go to the sorbonne philosophy
program and she was also I think the
eighth woman ever to to graduate from
that program so she was very special she
was very intelligent and
um she could hold her own with with the
you know the the the men who also became
famous philosophers including people
like Maurice Merlot Ponte and and others
um and yeah and so it was at the salon
where she met
um Jean-Paul sart and
um they fell in love uh but they
um didn't have a well from the very
beginning they they wanted to give each
other plenty of Freedom so they sort of
they they talked briefly about marriage
but they're like no let's let's make
sure that we're both free to
um fall in love with other people and
not just have sex with other people
because just being free to sleep around
is kind of a cheap like use of freedom
but they're like no let's be more
ambitious and give each other the
freedom to actually fall in love with
other people which
of course comes with a lot of other
issues and you know there are a lot of
jealousies and a lot of
um uh a lot of different problems
um but uh yeah but they tried to walk
the walk right I mean they tried to
their they tried to walk the walk they
tried to live up to the philosophy they
were developing
they did and what's also interesting
about that is yeah so they tried to you
know give each other Freedom like
Embrace Embrace freedom and and live as
well as as as you know with as much of a
varsity as they could and not be kind of
um dragged down by Bourgeois
institutions and and Bourgeois values
and um to be locked into into marriage
but
and with their experiences in in
um involving other people one of the the
big issues was that people would get
hurt along the way
um and sometimes hurt very deeply and
it's interesting the way the one such a
kind of handled that and and negotiated
their responsibility why say negotiated
I mean I guess I mean discuss their
responsibility
um because fine she and sat had made
this pact to
um to treat each other as primary like
um as most the most important
relationship in each other's lives and
then other people were kind of secondary
or contingent but those other people
weren't existential philosophers and and
so borvoir I guess later and she did
write in a letter and in some of her
memoirs that um she felt later that they
were responsible for a lot of the the
hurt and
um sort of she she did come to a bit of
a reckoning
um in a way that Jean-Paul Sartre
doesn't seem to have done in the same
way but you know and and one of the the
questions that people sometimes bring up
and that that I think about and I talk
about this in my book is that if bouvoir
and satra agreed to that
relationship as Primary in each other's
lives then even that limits their
freedom to
um have other relationships that might
have might be become so important that
they do challenge that that sort of
primary status of one another
um and especially for I think Simone de
Beauvoir because I mean in even John
Paul sartram yes they were very
interested in freedom but also they
emphasized how important responsibility
is in response that includes
responsibility to other people because
if you're just you know unrestrained
freedom
um then that sort of devolves into
Hedonism or egoism and that's not what
existentialism is That's So and it's the
the responsibility piece that that that
they emphasize because they what they
wanted to create a philosophy that does
acknowledge that we have relationships
and debts to other people
I mean maybe it's a cautionary tale or
at least uh I'm not a cautionary tale I
guess let's be totally unfair was there
relationship a success overall
well they would say they said it was
they said explicitly it was they both
did and so I am reluctant to judge
whether their relationship was a success
or not I'm like okay that's up to them
they they they chose that they freely
chose it
um but also I I want to make clear that
just because you're you're taking on
existential principles or you know
um kind of talk kind of um uh studying
existential philosophy to be okay
I was going to say to be an
existentialist but not if because you
can't because their idea is that we're
always growing and transcending and so
so to box ourselves into a role or a
label is is problematic but I want to
say that
um even if you Orient yourself in
um existentially authentic ways it
doesn't necessarily mean that you have
to have an open relationship at all
um what it means is that you
are um that you I mean even before
talked in The Second Sex about how an
authentic marriage is possible if two
people come together and are you know
really Lucid about what they're agreeing
to and don't try and drag each other
down into these traditional patriarchal
roles with the women doing most of the
home housework and men going off to to
be Breadwinners and as long as people
can come together and agree to terms of
the relationship themselves on their own
terms then you can still have a
monogamous even marriage under those
terms so yeah it's not so and also
pointed out she's like don't take me as
a role model like I'm choosing my
authentic path I'm orienting my life in
authentic ways but that doesn't mean
for you to be authentic you need to earn
your life in the same ways you've got to
work it out for yourself
well taking that to its extreme
um I mean I take the point about just
following in with traditional gender
roles that's you know that's sort of
arguably not the most authentic thing to
do you're just doing what Society tells
you to do but there has to be a space
for even if it's a tiny number of people
some couples want the traditional gender
roles right that's their authentic
desire and then the the tricky part
would be making sure that it is their
authentic desire and not that they're
just folding in the face of societal
pressure
yeah absolutely and I think Boulevard's
point was that you know we're not going
to know if that would be your authentic
choice
until you truly have a choice that you
can make with that and the way Society
is now especially in the US
so many people we're channeled into the
path of marriage there are so many like
tax benefits and and health insurance
benefits and perks to getting married
it's like the society is built
um for us to channel us into into these
sort of paths and so all these sort of
pressures and structures around us do
distract us from what might otherwise be
um an authentic choice and how can you
make a purely authentic choice if the
the odds are weighed so heavily in in
One Direction and so yeah Boulevard was
um her point was like you know it's
important to actually be able to make a
free and and fair Choice and then you're
gonna know that you're choosing that
because you truly want it and not just
because you get a whole lot of perks
from doing that
well you mentioned the second sex I mean
maybe to tell people who are not
familiar with that book in particular uh
probably her most famous book right I
mean by by being a woman by experiencing
how women were treated this gave pavar a
special angle on existential philosophy
that is still very very resonant today
wrote it in night well she published it
in 1949
um and it's really all about how
femininity and masculinity are regulated
in in Us in well in French society but
also you know in in our society too and
this is why it's still so relevant
because these themes are are we still
see these themes coming up and what her
point was that policing these
um these Norms about what women are
supposed to do and what men are supposed
to do limits all of us
um and
what her goal was was for all of us to
be able to start to become authentic to
to create ourselves on our own terms
um
but the problem is there are all these
structures and and norms and of society
and and tradition that are that will
punish us if if we don't conform and you
know for example now it's
um pretty accepted for women to wear
trousers and and men's clothes or or you
know young girls to wear men's clothes
but even boys wearing girls quote like
that's not a thing like
um boys
teased and they'll be though there's
punishment to that there's and so
um bouvoirs uh I think goal was let's
try and
um get rid of these kind of of these
policing
um uh Norms that
um and free free ourselves from those
kind of structures so that we can all be
free to express ourselves as we choose
and part of her book is all about how
um there are obstacles to becoming
authentic too expressing ourselves
freely in the world and you know and she
kind of goes through you know a bunch of
those obstacles like
um uh you know narcissism and you know
marriage is one and love being held up
as like the the ideal Destiny for all
women and something that all women want
um so yeah and she thought that you know
once we can kind of clear those
obstacles out of the way then we can
start to live fulfilling lives and start
to become authentic
the Norms are very strong sometimes you
know the cover of your book has uh uh
artistic representation of Simone de
bevoir and she's wearing a tie a
traditional masculine kind of garment uh
but there's no drawings out there of
jean-paul's out wearing a skirt right
you know
and but I I wonder about it I mean uh
it's it's a weird it's it's hard to
divide to to pinpoint the line between a
Norm just being oppressive of your
creativity or whatever or a norm acting
as a useful organizing principle for how
people get along in a society filled
with a whole bunch of different people
mm-hmm sure
um and I guess might say that how is
someone wearing a skirt useful in
organizing I think she would say or you
know okay she didn't talk about a skirt
necessarily but let's talk about
um uh an example she did talk about was
kids and how boys are encouraged to go
out and and rough house and climb trees
and you know it's okay if they come home
dirty but if a girl is to go out and get
her pretty white dress stained then or
you know get a scratch then often I mean
sure she was writing this in the 1940s
but you know it's still that we you know
we still see this today goals are meant
to be pretty girls are meant to
um you know girls are wearing makeup and
um high heels and that's still not
accepted for men to do that and so you
know's point was that
for all of us to be authentic what's
important is for us to be able to choose
how we present ourselves to choose how
we engage in the world and if there are
these
um you know uh kind of policings and
Norms that that don't serve anyone
except you know the traditional
patriarchal way of doing things then
then that's a problem
no that's a very good point I mean
asking who is being benefited by the
enforcement of these Norms is always an
interesting question to ask
um I guess and I'll just say that sorry
can I just say I'll say that on you know
and yeah we're talking about children
but this flows through and we're still
seeing you know pipeline problems in in
stem fields which is still dominated by
by men and girls struggle in those
fields
um so it's yeah so this kind of you know
in Bourgeois point was that these kind
of
um Norms
um uh get stronger and stronger as as
people grow older
yeah yeah no I guess I this I'm not
articulating this very well because I'm
like 99.9 on exactly on her side I think
a lot of norms are made up they're
usually made up for either arbitrary or
bad reasons but then there's like the
norm that in the United States we drive
on the right side of the road right
that's a very useful social coordination
kind of norm and I'm just mentioning
that I I can't see a very simple way to
delineate the difference between the
useful norms and the just restrictive
Norms so that's ongoing work yeah
oh yeah and I'm so glad you brought that
example up
um because this um you know one of the
um things that the existential
philosophers were pushing back against
was you've probably heard the the famous
quote from Dostoyevsky that says
something like if God is dead anything
goes and so the existential philosophers
were like if God is dead that does not
mean that anything goes and so they were
working towards trying to figure out you
know how to create a kind of Ethics that
isn't based on religion
and so and in fact and so Kika guard I'm
gonna go back to kick on for a second
um but he talks about how
um okay a couple of different spheres of
life but there's the aesthetic sphere
where you know you're you're enjoying
life and going around and being
frivolous and and you know having a lot
of sex and stuff and so this sort of
embodies the aesthetic realm but what he
says is that that's
um like a meaningless um well I mean it
there is some meaning in it because it's
a beautiful way of life but what he said
is that what we need to do is make an
existential choice to
um leap into the ethical realm of of
life where we acknowledge that we do
live with other people
um and so here's one of his
recommendations from his book either or
is that
um you know we should get married is one
of the things and he says that marriage
increases our freedom because it gives
gives us a sense of stability and
constancy and so if you know that you
have a partner there who's going to be
supportive of you then that actually
releases you to go and and enjoy your
life and in in in some ways which is the
same as you your example with with
driving on the right side of the road
yes we need some basic rules drive on
the right side of the road and in fact
that role increases freedom for everyone
because we all know we can go out and
drive mostly safely on that side of the
road and we're free to travel around and
go places good yeah okay that's actually
very clarifying thank you
um one of the things about existential
philosophy is it's often talked about
and what we've been talking about is it
can seem to focus on ourselves
individualistically a little bit and not
so much on other people but I I do think
that one of bavar's points is the other
with a capital O not just us that we're
talking about other people but
specifically the worry that we treat
others as objects rather than subjects
is that a the right way to put it
yes yeah
um so yeah and and this also relates to
authenticity because often when we think
about being authentic it's like an
individualistic kind of introspective
process but
thought that there were a couple of
different dimensions to our being sure
one of those is being for ourselves but
the other really important aspect of our
existence is being for others
um and why because other people reveal
aspects of our being that we can't
always see on our own you know like the
the saying the I can't see itself like I
can't see my own eye right now I need to
look in a mirror or I need you to tell
me what my so I need something else to
to give me insights into what my eyes
look like or or you know my actions you
know I can't always tell when my
writing's bad I need a friend or an
Editor to tell me
um and so Well's point and and you know
satra and some of the other
existentialists talk about this as well
is that you know we learn about
ourselves through engaging with other
people and you know I'm learning through
the questions you're asking me and
hopefully people are learning through
through these responses as well and so
if we're purely being for ourselves then
okay that's that's very individualistic
and narcissistic and self-centered
um but and this is something before I
talked a lot about in The Second Sex if
we're all at The Other Extreme being for
others that's dangerous too because like
traditionally women have been pushed
into that role of being for others at
the expense of being for themselves and
they've been treated as the second sex
like secondary to men whereas men have
been the primary the subject women have
been treated as other
um and so borwa's point was like both
extremes are problematic but what we
need to find is
a more harmonious kind of being with
others where we try and balance being
for ourselves balance with being for
other people and there's no specific
formula for getting to that balance
because it's going to be different
depending on the situation depending on
the context depending on the choices
that we're making fine I may have to
empty the dishwasher for the second time
today just because I understand that my
partner is has got as has to work late
or whatever but
as long as I realize that that that
doesn't um if if that happened all the
time that would be a problem exactly but
if it happens of course it's always
going to be a given or take and as long
as you know the relationship is
generally equal and as long as we
generally find a good balance then I
think that can be an authentic
relationship
well let's mention that your previous
book was existentialism and romantic
love uh which I will confess I haven't
read but I'm going to conjecture that
part of the lesson there is treating
your partner as a person with being in
themselves rather than just a object
Furnishing your personal life
yeah exactly that's that's a good
conjecture
discussion but
yeah and you know I look at a few
different perspectives there but yeah
the the key one and actually my favorite
which was why I went on to write this
next book
um about specifically about bouvoir was
because her ideas on
um authentic love were that love is a
mutual recognition of of two freedoms
and neither person you know annihilates
themselves and both
um support each other and support each
other's flourishing and both
um kind of contribute to the universe
together and so I really love this kind
of very positive
um not
um and I was going to say equal
relationship but what I mean is not you
know strictly equal is everything has to
be 50 50 but definitely this like
acknowledgment that you know
relationships are Dynamic and this this
it's it's the mutual respect or the term
she uses is inter-subjectivity so I
recognize that you're a subject you
recognize that I'm a subject and we
recognize we're objects for each other
but we um we really just treat each
other as as as humans with with dignity
and respect
I don't know how much you've dug into
recent controversies about incels and
the incel movement have you read a lot
about that
a little bit but I'm
spotting that I think I'm certainly not
an expert either in involved
involuntarily celibate uh Community
which you you might think of as like a
description that you reluctantly admit
amongst yourselves but it's become a
little point to Pride among certain
people they have their own Wiki where
they discuss their view of the world and
I think that I don't again I'm not an
expert but maybe this is a big part of
what they're missing that they have a
view in which
women in particular are supposed to play
a certain role in their lives in the
incel's life and they refuse to do it
and it doesn't really fit in rather than
treating other potential people romantic
partners and otherwise as subjects in
themselves as agents with their own uh
concerns and cares and and need for
authenticity
yeah I think that one's right and um I
think that's yeah Ami estranivasan talks
about this in in her book that came out
not so long ago called the right to sex
but what I did in line also apparently
that that the original incel website was
started by a woman who was um
involuntary so environment so
um but it got a you know taken over by
men
um but yeah I I think I would agree with
your analysis there as two people who
don't really know a lot about it we're
free to agree with each other
um
there let me ask about one aspect that
you talk about in The Book of devore's
philosophy that I'm I'm not sure whether
I buy into completely which is not which
is the idea that we not only have
freedom and we seek authenticity but
there's a role that is a very strong
role played for Rebellion for you know
resisting the
I don't know the the expectations the
typicality the conventional way of doing
things and I I can certainly imagine
that for some people that's super
important and that's what gives their
life meaning Etc but I can also Imagine
That for other people
happiness and fulfillment and
contentment is found by you know having
a job bringing home the bacon having a
happy family life uh watching sports on
weekends and then that's it and they
don't really want to rebel they kind of
like the standard Norms is that is the
idea of bavar or other existentialists
that they're making a mistake or that
it's okay not to be them
um
so I think first of all I think I would
say you should be free to live your life
however you choose but if you're kind of
sticking your head in the sand and like
isolating yourself from whatever's
happening in the rest of the world then
that you're missing out on on a big part
of life and so her I think her main
concern was that
um
that she said that Justice can never be
created within Injustice and so her
point is that if we respect freedom for
ourselves if we respect authenticity for
ourselves then we must respect it for
other people otherwise we're being
Hypocrites and
her and so
what she wanted to challenge us is to
not just hide ourselves away but
actually like engage in the world and
look at how other people are are being
oppressed and because
so many people are prevented from
exercising their freedom from prevented
from making free choices about how they
want to live their lives and if our
freedom comes at the cost of oppressed
people's freedom then she would think
that that's inconsistent and and deeply
problematic and so as long as there is
oppression in the world then
Rebellion is an important part of
becoming authentic
um because
really what she wanted to do was to
recreate the foundations of the world on
human Freedom instead of impression and
it goes back to your driving analogy if
we're all as long if we're all free to
drive on the right hand side of the road
if there are rules that says yep
everybody's free to drive on the right
hand side of the road then that means
that all of us are are free
and so we can navigate around the world
safely
um if other people are allowed to do
that too
um and so she actually goes back to a
kind of a stoic idea here and which is
that humanity is like stones in an arch
and the sturdier the individual stones
and the study of the structures then
then the sturdier the arch so as long as
all this if all the stones are healthy
then humanity is healthy if everyone
within is healthy
um and so that's so she was trying to
also take existential Philosophy from
you know this sort of as it has as you
mentioned a reputation for being more
individualistic to saying yes okay other
people are not just important for us to
understand ourselves but the way we
engage with other people and get along
with other people has implications for
the health health of humanity and the
societies we live in and so she was sort
of taking it to that even higher level
yeah no that's actually very interesting
to me because I guess I didn't
appreciate that
um it is a more demanding
way of looking at the world if you say
that okay a single individual might be
you know entirely
in favor of Rights and freedom for other
people but they don't do anything about
it they they let oppression and lack of
Freedom exist in the world without
taking action against it that in some
sense they're complicit I guess is what
you or she are saying
yeah yeah exactly but and and the other
thing I'll mention is that she's not
saying oh you have to go out and March
on the streets or create you know she's
not like dictating what you should do
about it because she's like we're we're
all individuals we've all got uh
pressures on on us in different ways you
know some people have kids that they
need to take over some people have jobs
that they absolutely need to go to and
so she was very
um uh understanding that you know we all
face different pressures in our lives
but I think what she was responding to
particularly was that she herself was in
a in big or came into a very privileged
position as you know a famous writer and
she was looking for ways to use that
privilege for good and so she did very
much get involved in in activism and um
and you know changing laws around
um access to contraception and abortion
and which led to real changes in in the
law and so what she was encouraging us
to do is just like yeah look a lot of us
are just focused on Survival but those
who are in privileged positions who have
the power you know it's it's we have a
responsibility to
help other people
um and you know how you know she made
mistakes on in how she helped other
people you know she was criticized in in
for various things but I appreciate how
she she did try to to use her power for
good and did try to change the world for
the better
now that's a that's an excellent point
in excellent distinction because I
always worry that the class of people in
whom I definitely belong uh who write
books and have podcasts and the
chattering classes who you know live
pretty comfortable middle class lives
are constantly telling other people how
they should live their lives and I and I
worry about that and I don't want to do
that too much but if she's drawing a
distinction saying look once you are
fairly privileged uh your
responsibilities shift a little bit like
like you say sure some people just have
got to make it through the day right
like it takes all of their effort just
to you know keep things going and and
and uh
live from day to day pocket uh paycheck
to paycheck I should say whereas others
you know have some space in their lives
to try to agitate to try to make things
better and then it becomes a
responsibility to do something like that
yeah I think that was where she was
going and you know she wasn't as I said
she's not saying oh you have to get out
and protest or sign petitions or
whatever she's like you know we do you
have a responsibility to do what you can
whether it is
creating a podcast to provide a platform
for interesting ideas that help people
understand their world better or are
writing books to do the same like that's
I think she would have thought that you
know as long as you're working towards
uh supporting human freedom and doing it
in responsible ways then
um that and by responsible I mean or she
meant that um you're not creating new
forms of Oppression and you know
restricting other people's freedoms in
in creating these freedoms
um but you know she also acknowledged
that the world is so complex and
um we can't always know like what we're
doing or the consequences of our actions
but she was optimistic that we can make
changes for the better and if people in
positions of privilege and power can
make small steps towards improving the
conditions for people who are less
privileged and she was saying that if
you if you're in that position you have
a responsibility to try
very good uh I guess for the last thing
I wanted to touch on you already alluded
to the fact that she and other
existentialists would very clearly use
fiction as a way of discussing
philosophical ideas
um
I I can imagine that writing fiction is
kind of fun maybe it increases your
sales of philosophy books what is it
intellectual justification for choosing
fiction as the medium in which to
discuss ideas like this what's the
advantage there
yeah so cute called it indirect
communication
so it was so he wrote fiction and or and
and he wrote Under pseudonyms
because he wanted to release the reader
from preconceptions about him the author
and so what that does is with with
fiction what it does is it
it's not
or or me saying oh this is what what I
think this is what you should think
rather it puts the responsibility back
on the reader to
figure out their own meaning and take
their own messages away from from the
writing and so what a lot of these
existential philosophers in particular
were really without challenging readers
to
um make up their own minds challenging
readers to to think for themselves
rather than just accepting
um you know uh objective truths or just
accepting things from from themselves
cue God was particularly annoyed with
the clergy you know people would you
know in in Denmark would plot off to
church and just you know get told the
clergy would tell them what to think and
and kirigard was like no that's we need
to teach people to to think for
themselves and think critically and and
not just go along with the herd and so I
think that's what fiction can do like
challenge us to to consider the nuances
of
different situations and contexts and
and think about how the different
situations apply to our own lives and
fiction can often do that in in ways
that you know Journal articles or you
know philosophical strict philosophical
essays
um in a way that they don't always
are you planning a novel
I'm not none but no maybe I should of
course you should that'd be great I mean
you know we've all wrote fiction when we
were kids and then we you know it was
beaten out of us but maybe this is your
perfect excuse
yeah yeah I'll give them some thought
thanks for the ideation
well we're looking forward to that
happening I think it would be great I'm
definitely going to be uh someone who
buys it so Sky Cleary thanks so much for
being on the mindscape podcast thank you
Sean thanks for having me this has been
fun
[Music]
mama